[Musique]
ce que vous voyez dans le bâtiment jaune voici
l'endroit où
le fondateur du bâton de menthe poivrée à
grenade amalia exxon a vécu
pendant près de 50 ans
nous avons eu cette photo de cette dame à l'
âge de 80 ou 90 quelque chose
elle est née en 1824  ici à grana et
mort à l'âge de 99 ans
[Musique]
et le portugais est tordu rouge et
blanc tordu comme la danse qui tourne en
rond c'est pourquoi le nom
polka de la danse en grèce
ou cochon
pour les petits bonbons en suède
la ville  est tout au sujet du steak à la menthe poivrée
ou de la polka la grèce il y a 10
12 usines le long de cette route principale la boule
s'est remise à
produire juste des bâtons de menthe poivrée
ou des poltergeists des bulgaris des
portugais
donc c'est
une gamme de saveurs comme vous voyez nous en avons
beaucoup  différentes saveurs
mais c'est
la bande rouge et une bande blanche
et
avec une saveur de menthe poivrée c'est l'
original
qu'Amalia a inventé en 1859
ça a bouilli à
145 degrés Celsius environ
et puis on verse la pâte sur cette table
[Musique]